[Music]
[Applause]
thanks dick for a wonderful introduction
yeah we worked together for seven years
that's 49 dog years but anyway so just
wanted to tell you a little bit about a
few things that are actually on the
unofficial google data science blog by
the way we we now also have google data
science com if you do that it will
directly forward you to the unofficial
google data science blog the reason for
this is that it's it got too hard to to
to tell people why we call ourselves the
unofficial google data science blog it's
it doesn't matter which it's probably
all fine anyway so this is just a
condensed version of some of the things
that are in one of the posts there that
i wrote back in january so those are you
are reading the blog thank you very much
and i apologize for regurgitating some
of the stuff okay so this is kind of
like a hypothesis here that i'm making
an argument you guys can disagree with
it that the scalable web technology is
what's burned a lot of data science it
was true for me personally but and i
think it was too for lots of people i'm
not saying it's exclusively the case but
you know scalable web apps and web
technology in apps gave rise to what i'm
calling LS OSL sauce which is
large-scale online services these are
basically everything that we see today
lift is included Google is included
facebook is included lots and lots of
businesses and services that we use all
the time each of us without thinking
anymore and what was interesting about
it which happened I guess in the late
90s whatever is especially if you don't
have any physical goods that are moving
then the marginal costs of serving an
additional user is basically going to 0
it doesn't you know the variable cost of
small you may have to spend a lot of
money building up a data science team
building up the technology but once you
have it in place it's just you can just
scale volume very very cheaply and that
led to first competition to get user
engagement because if you can do this
then so
your competitor it's all about you know
trying to attract people trying to get
them there and so there's a need for
constant improvement because there's
this fierce competition going on and
that leads to us having lots and lots of
data and experimentation and analysis
and then of course with all this data
comes the need for inference and that
means for you and me right so this is
this is good stuff we're happy about
this ok so I used to work in speech
recognition in grad school at least
briefly and there there was a saying
back called there's no data like more
data that's this is from the 80s and so
you know more data is actually better
for lots of things in particular there
are lots of inference techniques
modeling techniques will have you that
improve automatically with the more data
you throw at them they did a hungry and
so I like to use this term smod which is
a simple matter of data right certain
you want to work with problems where if
you throw more data it just gets better
it it makes everything easier and if you
work and one of these big companies you
have more and more data and many of you
are data engineers I mean your job is to
bring us the data and feed it to these
beasts hungry beasts and you know
everything gets better live randomized
experiments are also pretty important
because most business questions are and
this took me only 10 years to understand
this but it most business questions are
actually questions of causal inference
people want to know is this a caused B
that's really what they want to know so
how do you get causal inference there's
lots of complex techniques in many
situations but the best case scenario is
is if you can do a randomized experiment
now Nick went into situations where
that's not doable in certain situations
because there's this interference but
assume here for the sake of this talk
you can actually silo off users and
therefore you can run randomized control
case study us or control treatment
studies okay so that's a gold standard
great the more data you have the better
it is the faster you things will go and
my boss at the time and now again my
boss died and tang and others wrote this
paper called overlapping experiment
infrastructure more better faster
experimentation you can read about it
it's it's what made the ad system at
google the search ad system so efficient
because we were able to
run large amounts of experiments very
very fast okay all great so given enough
data any true effect will become
statistically significant I assume you
guys all know a little bit about
hypothesis testing so I'm won't belabor
too much but you know if you have enough
data if the effect is true eventually
you'll be able to determine it and so
that's so i will say that statistical
significance is smod it's a simple
matter of data if you have enough data
and this effect is true you'll get
significance out of it that's that's
pretty comforting let's see excuse me I
got to keep an eye on the time ok so
then there's of course practical
significance and again this is probably
well known to most people but just give
me a slide here statistical significance
is about is there is basically answering
the question is the difference I'm
seeing in my experiment in control let's
say is it due likely do the chance or is
this something I can sort of believe
that's what statistical significance is
about it's about uncertainty practical
significance is something else it says
well does anybody care do does it matter
what will I do with it and it is about
the purpose of what the conclusion
you're going to draw so maybe business
objectives or what have you that kind of
thing so they're they're quite different
in terms of what you're trying to do so
let's take a quick example okay so I
just I was coming to lift I made up this
slide our lift users taller than uber
users so imagine I do a hypothec of
study and essentially what i do is that
i do this study and assume everything is
kosher I did everything correctly and it
turns out that the difference in average
height of lift users versus uber uses is
point 01 inches plus or minus point 0 0
2 inches with ninety-five percent
confidence so that is to say that it's
statistically significantly true that
lift users are slightly taller than uber
users ok so then out comes the news
flashes out lift users are significantly
taller now is this true is this false
right I mean
it's kind of true and it's kind of
foster depends what you mean
statistically significantly taller yes
practically significant taller no
question i mean i don't think i don't
think we'll be getting bigger cars for
lyft users because of this right so it's
not kind of matter okay so um so
statistical significance as i said was
smod give it enough data any true effect
will be statistically significant but in
the world of data in the world of in all
our data there it's replete with Baron
truths truths that don't lead anywhere
they're not they're true but who cares
we need better hypotheses mere
difference is not super interesting
right just the fact that they're taller
by some some amount isn't interesting ok
so now I'm going to go through my logic
here which probably is flawed but let's
see if you can see it so imagine I've
got some important metric em and I about
hypothesis I say that ok this metric and
treatment minus the metric and control
has to be bigger than Delta and the
reason i put in delta there is because i
don't want to go back to the previous
thing where something is trivially small
so delta is chosen so that it's
practically significant the minimal
practical significance bar let's say for
what metric m is okay so here's the
logic statistical significance is smod
so it's just about data I have tons of
data because I have made millions
billions whatever lots of users
therefore a small experiment will show
if my hypothesis is true not the five
ninety-five percent confidence is it is
that is that true is that I mean is that
can I conclude that I guess some people
are suspicious okay so it's not always
true right but let's imagine if it were
true what would that mean I have tons of
data right so everything can be answered
if it's true I will very quickly know
that it's true if this were true the
implications are rather disturbing for
you and me why okay so there's no need
to do experiment sizing because one
percent is small enough its peanuts
making it point seven percent is not
interesting so that's fine no need to be
sophisticated about estimating
statistical significance because you
know the error bars are too small to
care right so at Google for example we
have a cottage industry we have somebody
sup a chart and doesn't put error bars
somebody in the audience is where the
error bars but in this case sometimes
they're too small to matter right and so
that's a good answer by the way
sometimes and so any useful useful
hypothesis can be quickly tested so
that's great but then you know what gets
what pms are going to run everything
because they're the ones coming up the
hypotheses no we we can probably fire
all the data scientists we may still
have to keep the data engineers that
don't worry those of you are coming from
the data engineering side the SF data
science people have to be worried and
you know we at least we don't want to
waste the data scientists on experiment
design analysis because there's nothing
really there to do it's all relatively
trivial so this does happen sometimes I
actually was interviewing somebody from
a well-known online movie downloading
site which I will not describe but
anyway and I heard that this is what
they don't think of that's fine right
they don't think that experiments are
about statistical uncertainty for them
it's all simple and trivial luckily for
the rest of us it's not because because
if you were we'd be out of a job so yes
statistical significance is simply a
matter of data but Delta is often so
small that we still don't have enough
data now that seems contradictory but
we'll get to in a second not even when
you have billions and millions of users
and why because it turns out because
every observation has very little
information towards answering the
question you care about okay so let's
see so now just a little bit of math but
nothing fancy so imagine the simplest of
cases you have two populations there's
the control population with a mean and
variance and then the treatment
population has the mean plus Delta and
the same various okay so the effect size
traditionally speaking if you guys study
statistics is for a t-test to population
a sample set up is the difference in
population means as a fraction of the
standard deviation okay that's kind of a
traditional way to describe this so and
an effect size of point2 would be
considered small my sister is a
psychologist and they are not interest
even they're not interesting point
too right okay sorry she's she's in San
Diego but you know all right so
sophistical significance is smod so
going back to this what is it so if you
have two samples and let's say until
there's the harmonic mean of the sample
sizes you don't have to worry about the
details here and alpha is the continued
no type 1 error rate beta is the type 2
error rate then you get significant
significance is if this condition is
true which is very much to say if you
stick in typical values of point oh five
and ten appoint ten percent you say if
the effect size times the square root of
the sample size the pooled sample size
is greater than someone right so if I if
I get enough data that means until this
big enough I will be able to get
statistical significance regardless of
how small e is but it's also true that
if E is super duper small then I need
more and tilda right so that's that's it
that's a trade-off okay now we'll go to
the notion of practical significance so
here I'm going to define this term for
which I will become famous someday
called effect fraction which is to say
it is the size of the effect the Delta
the difference in group means divided by
the mean not by the standard deviation
okay so now who the hell cares the
reason is that this is how most people
think about what they do if i have a
metric i say i got a two percent
increase in my metric let's say it's the
number of the ETA let's say the lift how
long it takes somebody to show up it's
two percent not a fraction of the
standard deviation but two percent of
the mean this is what normal people that
is to say non statisticians think about
when they think of things and that's why
I'm calling it affect fractions it
sounds like effect size but it's not
really that okay so in this context a
point 0 2 percent can be practically
significant it depends what you're doing
so in the Google search ads world you
know they're making something like 50
billion dollars a year two percent is
nothing to sneeze at is more than what
they would pay us so that's kind of
that would be a big deal okay so it
depends on what you're doing and I think
in most cases if it's a important metric
for lift whatever I think a two percent
change would be a big deal okay going
back to the statistical significance of
practical significance in different way
so imagine f was the effect fraction he
was the effect size the ratio between
these is the coefficient of variation
which is to say Sigma divided by me it's
the standard deviation divided by as a
fraction of the mean okay so with some
advanced math we can see that if X is is
is the effect fraction divided by the
coefficient of variation which is to say
the bigger your coefficient of variation
is the more it's going to shrink your FX
sighs okay so this coefficient of
variation comes to comes to be something
very important and the bigger it is the
harder it is for us to do what we need
to do okay so what I'm going to make the
case is that the larger bigger
coefficient of variation makes us
information poor okay well obviously
because it shrinks our effect size so
therefore it gets harder to make
statistically significant discoveries
but it's another more direct way to
think about it is that the coefficient
of variation is is a measure of how much
information observations have towards
measuring a mean so for example if I was
going to you know take the sample
average to estimated mean the standard
deviation of my estimate would go as a
square root of 1 over square root of N
and so the fractional error that i have
in estimating the mean mu is the
coefficient of variation divided by
square root of n so it comes up here
right so the bigger this is the more
percentage error i'll have an estimation
it gets pretty fundamental that way
right okay so now let's think about
coefficient variation when you have rare
events suppose I have I don't know pick
something people click on ads which is a
rare thing I don't know why they do it
but it's it keeps the lights on or you
know
I people open the lift app or you know
it's probably a rare event so to speak
or maybe I guess a better case would be
somebody clicks a like button right so
there's lots of interactions but very
rarely there's a like click or something
like that so now imagine why is whether
there was a like click or not and say
Bernoulli random variable binary with
probability P so the coefficient of
variation if you calculate it it's just
the binomial probability square root of
that divided by the mean and that turns
out to something like 1 over square root
of P so if P is small a rare event this
thing gets bigger and bigger okay so
that's so your coefficient of variation
is essentially the rare of the event the
larger the coefficient variation which
going back will shrink your effect size
and therefore make life difficult for
you in experiments so rare events are
you know rare events and small effect
fractions a kind of part of the
landscape of large-scale online systems
often services um so let's go through
the logic here and I'm getting close to
the end here so low marginal costs mean
the business can rely on monetizing rare
events what do I mean by that so take
take something where there's a service
it's a glorious service and pick your
favorite door service where most of it
is free it's just free so how the hell
does this happen well because there's a
few rare events that monetize things
that pay for the whole show ok so in
search ads world search which is
incredibly expensive to run is all free
but once in a while somebody clicks on
an ad and that makes everything work for
that funds everything a person imagine
me I've got a personal finance website
it's free you can do all sorts of stuff
you can upload things you can check
stuff out and then once in a while I
might sell you a financial product and
it's a pretty rare event like a loan or
credit card or whatever and that will
keep the lights on for everything else
right so it's a rare event that does it
or a photo storage site I mean I think I
don't know what shutter flies business
model is but I'd imagine if I ran a
photo storage site and I said you got to
pay me ten bucks a month nobody'll do it
but if I say it's free okay free
everybody loves for
a-and but once in a while I'll sell you
a photo book this is like 60 bucks for
your I don't know kids birthday or
something like that and so I won't do it
very often but I'll do it just enough
that it will keep everything going right
so this is all possible because of the
scale a scalable technology at low
marginal marginal costs okay the other
thing that happens is that because
there's low marginal cost that is to say
it doesn't take anything to once you've
built the thing it doesn't take much to
service more and more users any growth
that you can push through by making
changes or what-have-you is going to hit
the bottom line because it's you know
transact you know moving bricks around
it's it's it's just all virtual and so
you'll make more money if you can get
more engagement more growth or whatever
whatever your metric is and so that's
why you know these large-scale online
services they often care about rare
events and they care about small effect
fractions both of them okay final slide
but there's some poetic justice here
perhaps right and this is my hopeful or
whatever enigmatic slide it says that so
large scale start with large scale our
web tech dries marginal cost down so
that means it's very easy to serve more
and more people it enables these online
services very large scale with lots of
users lots of experiments and their data
rich they've got tons of data because
they're very scalable the low marginal
cost enabled a business model which
relies on rare events and cares about
small effect fractions okay so that
makes every observation that they have
they've got tons of observations but it
makes every observation information poor
relative to what they care about so
therefore they have to run these massive
experiments that you know social
scientists don't have to run because
they're much more we you know in this
context were much more data poor
information poor now luckily these
large-scale online services do have lots
of users so it is some kind of balance
there you have tons of users but you
never have enough right it's kind of
like you always want more and that's
kind of the
conclusion of my my slides here so I
hope this is a is I hope I succeed in at
least giving you some connection however
10 years between business models and
statistics in terms of how certain
business models will promote a certain
kind of business and therefore therefore
create certain problems that tie back to
it and now you're going to introduce it
okay thank you
[Applause]